For me at least,
I don't really take anything for granted
is the way that I feel.
Because you see,
you see multiple ways of living,
you see your,
your express.
I think what happens here is that people
get so used to this idea of,
of,
of America as a place where anything and
everything should happen.
And you know,
where as Americans,
I think we're a very entitled bunch or
we,
you know,
and I think that having seen that,
that's not the case around the world.
You're very aware of that.
And I think everything here then takes
on a new meaning.
It's one that's not to say that,
that,
I mean like,
you know,
when you say something like that,
people can say,
oh well you think you're better than
everyone else.
That's not it at all.
I mean,
I think everybody's still falls into
that.
And I would say that I'm just as
entitled,
I feel just as entitled and probably
behave just as entitled as the next
American as the next person here.
I think at the same time having the
ability to step out,
right,
having the ability to be in another
place and see how people perceive you as
an American and then not just see,
but also actively participate in that
perception of Americans really is a self
check.
It's a way of looking at your,
your behavior as a member of this
particular society or this particular
culture.
And I think it leads to,
for me at least,
I feel like my life has completely
enriched.
I mean,
being Nigerian obviously are being a
Nigerian American also means that I'm a
black American,
which is also another set of
perspectives.
I mean obviously given the history that
black Americans have in this society,
it's different for me because I'm not,
you know,
I'm not,
my family doesn't go generations deep
here,
but you still experience the same things
and you still have that,
that,
that outlook and you still have that way
of seeing how things are put together in
this society.
And I think,
you know,
having,
again,
being in,
in,
in a weird way also not really being in
because you're,
you're part of this,
of,
of your black American,
right?
I am a black American,
but at the same time it's a different
version,
right?
And it's a multiple,
it's a different version.
It,
it allows,
I think having those different versions
of being a black American allows
multiple perspectives and,
you know,
different analysis of what being a black
American meetings.
I think all too often the society has to
monolithic definition of what a black
American is.
And I think having,
you know,
being a Nigerian man,
American being black,
being African adds to that definition,
at least in my own case.
Right?
And I think it helps,
uh,
in the largest sense if,
you know,
for all the people who are black
Americans from this part of the country,
from that part of the country,
if you are going to be an American,
if you're Nigerian American,
if you're Caribbean American,
to add nuanced and structure to that
definition of black American.
Um,
and so allow people to see that it's not
just one thing.
It's not just one culture,
that it's a multiplicity of cultures and
that's important both for,
for the recognition of that set of
people as full citizens and also for
the,
for the,
for the country as a whole.